using the catch the eye function on your
voting machine after having inserted
your voting code during Question Time
interventions were typically from place
from your seat and I invite all speed
speakers to stick to the allocated
speaking time
once again you can register through the
voting machine
and I'd like to ask you to do that right
now let's begin with the first question
is our first speaker
good afternoon
commissioner
president
we know that prices are going up Energy
prices are going up and that has
ramifications on the growth in food
prices
if we look at inflation
if we look at
how
the share of food prices as a part of
overall inflation
it's obvious that following on from
energy food prices constitute the second
biggest
share of payments and that has a massive
impact on consumers
but how did this kick off well we know
that there are farmers
who are not gaining anything from this
growth in prices they're dependent on
food stuffs being sold so my question to
the commissioner is
how do you want to make sure that
farmers are being supported because
they're suffering from inflation greatly
thank you very much
commissioner please
thank you thank you very much maybe some
some thank you uh Miss uh for your
question
yes we can observe the increase of the
the food prices that's uh General
inflation in European Union is the 11
comparing November to November 21 22
but food food inflation is 18 and 18.3
percent uh we can observe different
situation across the sector sectors
across the member states
but you write that farmers incomes
was increased in last year
13 but also there are differences across
the member states not everywhere they
increased but it is easy to to observe
that increase of the farmer's incomes is
less than increase of food prices
and
increase of
[Music]
agriculture costs comparing 2122
the the cost of production is about the
30 percent uh increase of agricultural
prices of agricultural products is 24 it
shows that increase of cost is not fully
compensated by the increase of prices
which Farmers receive and what we can do
of course you know the fertilizer prices
this is the main uh the main factor of
increase of the agriculture cost also
energy what you said we presented our
agriculture our fertilizer communication
that is possible support on the member
states level
support for the fertilizer producers for
the farmers
stated for the farmers possible amount
to 250
000 Europe per individual farm this is
the what we may main instrument which we
propose of course there is a common
agricultural policy but you know the the
Strategic plans but it will be in in the
future in the coming years implemented
thank you
in tank
thank you very much
thank you very much for that answer I do
have a supplementary question
commissioner
your answer is one I can't accept for
this year 2023
because
there's a calculation that inflation
will be taken into consideration
for funding the common agricultural
policy
does that mean that we'll be able to see
conditions extended and improved for the
use of the new common agricultural
policy because that would help farmers
as well
here I might add I'll be speaking polish
right now I can add that in our
communication on fertilizers we've
listed
ways of incar of encouraging industry
member states can alter their strategic
plans
as of the 1st of January
and we are listing ways of proposing new
ways of working that will make Farmers
less dependent on fertilizers
fertilizers have the greatest weight in
the content in the structure of cost so
there will be programs which will be
encouraging Farmers for instance to
produce their own fertilizer in a
natural way but many answers to your
question will lay outside of the realm
of cap and outside of the realm of
responsibilities of commissioner
responsible for farming and agriculture
we are thinking about
imposing caps caps on gas price we have
in the caps on gas prices and activities
that are undertaken across the board but
we are using a cap and public aid in the
individual member states this is what we
can do in short term thank you
fin tank
thank you very much commissioner for
Tchaikovsky uh colleague just we'll take
the fly now
thank you president
commissioner we know that the major
problem of
participation in Europe is not as a
result so much of of supplies but the
increases in Energy prices and the price
of fertilizers and it has to be said a
degree of speculation on the market has
all led to an up certain prices
and that is above all hitting the most
vulnerable families
we know
that there's a huge burden to their
family budget a lot of expenditure on
food
so we have vehemently defended the the
package of measures
a solidarity a package for families and
firms we've also called for ongoing
support measures
to keep energy costs down on the market
and so forth now what I would like to
know from the commission is this
what other measures
could be implemented not just to support
our Farmers but also to help
the most vulnerable families across the
European Union thank you
thank you very much
commissioner please
thank you very much for for this
question and uh no first of all but I I
like to to to mention that the situation
is different across the member states
increase of food prices is is the EU
average is
18.3 percent but we can in all member
states is more than 10 percent but the
less is in Luxembourg which is 10.8
percent the highest inflationist in now
in Hungary
49.2 percent
not good
I cannot exclude there is there is
speculation is one of the factors but
you know
it it is possible but the commission has
no evidence that now the the this this
is the responsibility of the of the
member states to act against the
speculation on the on the on the market
if if this is observed
uh
this is also the differences between the
the type type of products the uh about
the agriculture products the the main
increase of prices is for cereals about
the 45 percent
Nexus eggs milk more than 30 percent
and the rest less than less than 30
potatoes poultry pig meat and
the beef
Etc this is less than 30 percent
no thank you
thank you very much Commissioner of Kim
on this side of the chamber I don't know
whether you noticed or actually am
you seem to be looking constantly in
another Direction
rather than over here
well thank you for all the information
you've provided to us
come what me
I'm Keen to see what more the commission
can do to protect the interest of the
most vulnerable consumers I'm grateful
to you anyway and for the explanation
you've given us in those details thank
you
that's why it's kind of froggy meal
dungeons wasn't really a question
thank you chair
commissioner
if inflation is a problem in the
European Union then in Croatia it is a
huge problem because during the past two
months our inflation is more than 13
and if we speak about inflation now food
prices this is uh an extremely huge
problem
in Croatia we introduced you around the
first of January and the price is
skyrocketed somebody will say the
situation was similar in Italy and
Slovenia
but the Figures were much lower than
today in Croatia that is why I would
like to put a question are you aware of
this problem of synergy between
inflation and rounding up of prices
and in Croatia and whether you can do
anything in order to stop this trend in
order to protect the most vulnerable
citizens and to prevent them
from diving into poverty
College thank you very much
called the commissioner of
Arizona
thank you very much yes I can confirm in
Croatia I'm aware of it before the euro
already there was a problem because
Croatia has one of the highest inflation
rates when it comes to foodstuffs and
their prices
General prices have increased by
19.8 well this is an average for the EU
I'm not able to comment on what has
happened after the Euro has been
introduced we do not have full data in
this respect yet so I'm not well placed
to make comments on this but I have been
listening to you very carefully the data
which I have at my disposal compare
November 20 22 and November 2021
if you are asking about Croatia
precisely I can you I can tell you that
it was
19.8 percent inflation for foodstuffs
for cereals and bread and other cereals
bread products products 27.7 milk 26.5
and lower increases for vegetables and
fruit and other products thank you
here's an additional question
thank you very much for your reply which
actually confirms everything I have said
could you please provide a specific
answer to the question
will the fight against inflation of
prices of foodstuffs be your priority
for 2023 and if so which measures are
you going to apply thank you
thank you very much commissioner please
cool technology
yes well
in this debate what I can tell you is
about what we are going to do Under the
cap
neo-strategic plans are one such measure
to support farmers
our farmers are up to the task we have
seen it they are working under very
difficult circumstances the energy price
has skyrocketed the fertilizers the feed
all of this is increasingly expensive
but we still have food security thanks
to our Farmers we need to support them
using all the instruments which we have
at our disposal thanks to the cap
I would like to refer back to one of the
questions which perhaps I haven't
answered precisely there is an inflation
affecting the cep which is being
devalued the budget of the cap is about
5
55 billion Euro annually if you compare
it
to the value of the whole agriculture
production which has increased
due to inflation it has increased from
450 billion Euro to 536 billion Euro but
the expenditure on the cap has not
changed despite inflation despite the
increased value of agricultural
production we can now experience this
problem but of course the budget is
decided by the member states this
pertains to the whole budget of the EU
and to the budget of the cap
nowadays this budget might be less
effective and might be less of an
incentive for the farmers thank you
Phil tank a commission thank you very
much
commissioner
a colleague please you have the floor
thank you
thank you very much president good
afternoon commissioner thank you for
being here
because everybody who says inflation
refers to Energy prices of course but
obviously we need to look at food prices
as well that's what we're looking at now
food prices have gone up and we can see
symptoms there but we need to look at
the root causes as well given food price
inflation and inflation in general then
I think their problems of artificial
manure which whose prices have
skyrocketed if we look at artificial
manure we're dependent on third
countries non-eu countries heads of
state and government in their side
declaration said that we have to become
more independent of third countries and
they've even called for the
establishment of a European protein
strategy so my question to you is has
the European commission already worked
on this European protein strategy and if
so when can we expect a proposal from
you thank you
thank you
zato
thank you very much for this question
well yes
we must underscore the fact that
food prices are growing faster than
inflation big just because the increase
in the cost of production has affected
the food production much stronger to a
greater degree than other areas of
production the increase of energy prices
has affected the over the entire economy
but
farming has been affected by higher
prices of fertilizers
regardless of the prices of energy
so this is why inflation is so clearly
visible in the area of food products as
for fertilizers the European commission
has proposed
um everything that we could have
proposed within the realm of our
competences we have proposed all of
these instruments that could be applied
most of them are in the realm of
decisions of the individual member
states that may decide whether they wish
or not to provide support to their
domestic producers of fertilizers for
instance in Poland I know that this is
being envisaged this should lead to
lower to the lowering of prices of
fertilizer which will translate into
price food prices
but let us remember that not everything
will depend on
the cost of fertilizer
and that food products and food prices
are not exclusively dependent uh on the
activity of farmers
we've got we see that farmers are not
the beneficiaries of this increase in
food prices because some people try to
interpret it in this way they say well
prices have risen and so farmers are
receiving more for in exchange for their
products so their Position will be
better unfortunately and this is not the
case
farming Revenue has not risen to an
extent equal or sufficient to compensate
inflation and I hope that the new
strategic plans which are very flexible
and which are being proposed will help
us overcome the situation thank you
thank you very much commissioner thank
you very much much yes you're talking
about chemical fertilizers and indeed
I'm looking forward to your action plan
on integrated nutrient management and I
think we have a place there for that but
I'm talking about specifically the
timing of your European protein strategy
could you maybe give an answer to that
[Music]
um
well thank you very much I haven't
answered this question I am my apologies
yes we are working on this document and
at the at this point we don't know
whether this is going to be a strategy
or a communication from the European
commission this is not yet certain but
we are working on that we're working on
an idea a concept for the development of
protein
crops in Europe which is very important
in order to ensure a greater autonomy of
our farming and this is uh partly the
result of my statements during one of
the previous debates at the European
Parliament where I mentioned the need
for such a strategic approach to these
food groups and this document will
certainly see the light of day
thank you very much commissioner
the strike of balance
between the groups
and now
um we will close the list we have enough
individuals registered
if anybody has been left out then
we can register it afterwards but we
have numerous different individuals
registered now our next speaker is
called a code
the Commissioners some facts and figures
Poland today versus Poland eight years
ago bred 330
to day six Lotus the government can
afford it but 360 then now seven slotted
this is our welfare this is our El
Dorado the sunflower oil costs 13 pln
per liter this is your bread and water
plus the new benefit of the government
people are striving to make ends meet
people are pawning The Wedding lyrics
elderly people cannot afford medicines
public TV is not showing it we have 17
percent of inflation the effort for the
Eurozone is nine percent
have you issued some recommendations to
the Polish government about cutting
inflation have you identified some
specific instruments that should be
triggered if not please act quickly
thank you
thank you very much commissioner
um
well
I'm not sure if this is a question to me
I gathered that the social reflection
process on the prices in Poland
but if you look at those prices in
Poland is not the country that was
affected most in Europe some countries
have more than 50 percent
others fall somewhere between 30 and 40
percent Lithuania
31.34.7 Latvia
31.1 Estonia 29 percent
all those countries have a higher
inflation rate than Poland Romania
22.6 Slovakia 28 Poland has
22 percent
yes we are above the average as Poland
but we are not in a group of those
countries that were affected most
painfully we don't have any
recommendations for Poland now because
this is not the role of the commission
to issue such recommendations but even
if Poland wouldn't be one of the first
countries concerned because Poland is
doesn't have the highest inflation rate
in Europe
thank you very much
commissioner
now I simply wanted to say that we have
90 minutes for this
period we have 18 questions which are
possible and it's divided by the
different groups
we'll have to improve this particular
procedure so that it's all more
transparent for you now I have the
particular registrations
continually the Castro
and montlow
and then we have
libert
y they shall take the floor
uh
so if somebody is missing they can take
their place but
um we'll have to think about how we can
manage this in the future but anyway
colic wise you have the fluid chair and
the commissioner yes indeed energy and
energy inflation related to the Ukraine
war is the main driver of food prices
but there's two more factors that are
let's say not put in the light as much
as we need to on the one hand there's
the big food companies that have made
use of the crisis already during the
covet crisis raising the prices of the
food stuff they are providing to the
wholesalers in an illegitimate way that
even resulted to the very specific
situation that big wholesale companies
were threatening companies like Mars or
Nestle or Unilever to de-list their
products because they were not accepting
their race in prices do you have any
further information on that especially
on the windfall profits this resulted to
in these companies and the second factor
is speculation we're having speculation
on food as Commodities and it's not
about the question whether there's hedge
contracts for for fixed price production
dealt on the market but the question is
whether we allow speculation on Rising
or lowering food prices on grains on
pork meat and so on is there any
indication from your site now to
actually give us research on how much uh
on how much speculation contributes to
the food prices
foreign
thank you much Miss thank you very much
Mr Knights
commissioner
well certainly as I've already said
before we cannot exclude and rule out
speculation I would like to spell it out
very clearly that we
need
to save God
the competition and the rules governing
competition in the individual member
states and this is the responsibility of
the relevant bodies National bodies we
have not received any significant
signals indicating that speculation has
got a significant impact on food prices
no we see that the increase in food
prices is the consequence of Russia's
aggression in Ukraine and which
translated into also into Energy prices
all these cost factors had inevitably
had to find their reflection in food
prices
as for
the bodies the organizations that are
purchasing food
produce from Farmers well clearly
farmers are still the weaker party
facing those large
companies although the situation differs
from country to Country in some member
states farmers are better organized and
they are stronger and more united we
also have member states where there are
specific instruments that have been
introduced in order to strengthen the
position of farmers we also see such
proposals in the Strategic plans we also
have the directive which is which was
adopted in 2019 and which is currently
being implemented the directive on
combating
unfair practices in food trade so a lot
will depend on its adequate
implementation the directive proposes
instruments that will be protecting
Farmers against any form of abuse by
other Market bodies
thank you very much commissioner Mr
weitz
commissioner if we provide you with
concrete evidence and concrete
informations on actual speculation on
foodstuff that happened the last two
years will you ask your authorities your
services to actually do concrete
research on it and provide us with data
commissioner such information
we will very seriously consider
okay
Finance
thank you very much
well so you can see we can have
supplementary questions now please I do
beg your Indulgence
this question time is a new tool we've
been running it in for a few months it's
coming from the focus groups you have
recommendations and indications you can
see from your console if you're
registered or not if you leave then you
leave now we're still trying to optimize
the procedure the next speaker is Mr
Amaro
Mr
foreseen there is no reason to
comply a complain
president
thank you president commissioner
we know what we're talking about here
Farmers incumbent are not increasing in
line with other increases now it's
important that there be alignment
the the questioning because I see myself
and many other colleagues
is this and I'd like the commission to
be objective about this
in seeking to solve
this income gap you you've you've taken
to the next is what the commissioner has
said well let's answer just two things
the cap
and strategic plans within the cap
in the member states policies I'm sorry
commissioner it's really not very much
what we want
is for the commission to square up to
the real facts where Obama's incomes are
suffering you need special measures to
compensate them
the CMP wasn't designed to fight
inflation
it's unfair when it comes to defending
Farmers if we just refer to to the the
cap and the Strategic plans thank you
thank you Mr America
yeah
I can only agree with you
that the cap
and the entire EU budget
are not ready for this level of
inflation
we are always ready for some level of
inflation because we have a two digit
adjustment rate but we were not prepared
for the enormity of this crisis
first we had the pandemic now we have
the brutal work caused by the Russian
aggression this is a new situation
we were not in the situation when the
budget was adopted in July 2020 we
already had the pandemic but we had no
idea that soon there would be a war
ravaging Europe
this is a problem
because you rightly referred to specific
instruments
let me repeat one more time the
commission has done everything in its
power to increase the supply of food
this is decisive for the prices we have
suspended not revoked but suspended for
this year that provisions on
non-production areas that normally would
have to be set aside
the same applies to obligatory crop
rotation so we have suspended all the
instruments that would bring down the
production level we have triggered the
crisis Reserve we have the private
storage Aid
we wanted to remove all the obstacles
hampering the increase in food
production and
potentially
bringing up the prices I don't know what
else we could do some measures are
within the budget such as more money for
crisis interventions and we have 500
million euro under the crisis reserve
the crisis is huge so I concur with you
that this is not enough
all about it currently is
0.4 percent of the eugdp this is the cap
0.4
of the GDP and this policy is
responsible for food security and Earth
environmental security alike thank you
thank you very much commissioner voice
kovsky
Miss avram is the next speaker
thank you
thank you chair we see all these
statistics coming from the member states
from International organizations and
they are quite worrisome as the
consequences are Romania ended the year
2022 with a 22 percent increase in the
price of uh food products and this has
led to a gradual
dispiration of products from shops and
to the fact that the program for the
distribution of milk and fruits in
schools has been blocked half the
country because the farmers simply could
not afford to sell at those prices to
schools anymore over 40 percent of
Romanian children are now at risk of
poverty and social exclusion and
that meal that they were getting from
the school was maybe the only source of
food that they had during the day the
forecast for 2023 shows that uh 50 more
Romanians will live an absolute poverty
my question commissioner is do you see
any real solution to this crisis which
first and foremost affects children and
their food thank you
thank you Miss avram Mr commissioner
voice
and thank you very much for this
is
thank you very much inflation in Romania
is high although there is a number of
countries where inflation rates are
greater but in Romania the problem the
key problem is that income of farmers
has gone down I have been mentioning
that overall in the European Union we've
seen 13 hike in the revenue of farmers
but in Romania we see a 21 reduction in
farming Revenue Farmers Revenue this
this is very fresh data we will be
analyzing such data in the context of
individual member states and they are in
the entire European union
we need to perhaps envisage specific
action
um nobody has mentioned this so far but
during the discussion but we also see
very acute problems in member states
that have direct borders with Ukraine
because the consequences of the war in
Ukraine have been affecting farmers in
the those member states in a much more
acute way that's a problem of Poland
Romania Hungary Slovakia
free trade with Ukraine which is very
much needed and which is very strongly
supported by the European commission is
also leading to certain negative
consequences to Farmers in these
countries in these member states who are
facing difficulties with selling their
product produce and this is a problem
that we are currently analyzing and
perhaps we will need to think about
applying the reserve
the crisis Reserve in case of those
member states we are thinking about
improving the situation and returning to
the situation in Romania I believe that
there is a link between the two the
proximity of the war Arena this
proximity this neighborhood
issue is affecting especially those
member states which are the closest
thank you
thank you commissionerkovski the next
speaker is Miss sardony
foreign
milk 14 percent
eggs 50 percent
bread and cereals numerous different
percentages as well as far as the
increase in prices these are only
indicative of the situation in Italy now
in Europe what is the commission doing
about this situation what do they plan
to do my impression is is that they're
asleep uh criminalizing suppliers
Farmers
providing good circumstances for
synthetic meat to be produced but what
is going to be done now we have to have
some sort of system which penalizes
those which boost up or jack up the
prices for those reasons whatsoever look
at the situation in the wine sector as
well in this particular context I think
that indeed we need a new regulation
with regard to packaging as well which
would penalize any sort of counterfeit
products or illegitimate products as
well and have you taken into
consideration that
that the cost at this particular point
is the whole burden of it is being born
by consumers something has to be done
about this
thank you Mrs commissioner voice
thank you very much for this question
when it comes to Italy
you are better off than an average EU
country because the inflation of food
prices in the whole EU is 18.3 percent
but for Italy it amounts to
13.8 percent so you're better off your
significantly below the average for the
EU inflation
I cannot talk about all the activities
of the eel I have to focus on
agriculture and as far as agriculture is
concerned the recent Decisions by the
commission show that there is a
reflection process that we want to
facilitate that we don't want to make
lives more difficult for Farmers we have
a financial regulation concerning the
CPP including important Provisions
allowing not to penalize Farmers for
small irregularities which are not their
fault or which are a result of false
measure
so we are open-minded we do not want to
be repressive towards farmers
um
with regard to Italian agriculture I
think it's a good practice a good model
a good network of connections between a
production processing and local markets
there are many good examples here to be
followed by other member states yes the
input costs are higher so everyone is
affected
to a smaller or higher extent inflation
is painful to everyone farmers are
struggling with input costs everywhere
but as I have already said Italy is
anyway better off than other member
states thank you
thank you commissioner voice
now Mr Ilitch
yeah
commissioner the market has a clear
principles of actions and it's difficult
for politics to prevent it if there is a
surplus of a particular product the
price Falls and then if there is a
deficit the price is higher the growth
of food prices that we talk about now is
certainly the consequence of the reduced
production especially in the European
Union because of the high ecological
standards that are the highest in the
world
in addition during these 17 days when
according to the president of the
European commission we have successfully
introduced the euro in Croatia food
prices have increased an additional 20
percent and according to studies
presented at the committee for
agriculture the production of food in
the EU will continue to be reduced as
well as Farmers revenues and we will
have to import more and more food from
third countries of dubious quality
therefore I'm asking if the commission
will work
on the fact that the same ecological
standards are going to requested of food
imported from third countries the ones
uh produced in the EU thank you
thank you Mr commissioner
um
well yes of course those equal standards
and the application of the reciprocity
rule in trade with third parties
is a constant item during all of our
negotiations concerning free trade
agreements which are being concluded
with Partners such as for instance in
New Zealand recently
these Provisions are always implemented
on the other hand we need to respect the
rules of the WTO
which is not always very easy to it is
not always very easy to ensure that
elevated EU standards can be adhered to
whenever they go beyond the World Trade
generalized standards because in certain
cases they might be seen as unwarranted
unjustified barriers to trade because we
don't and we don't want the European
Union to be seen and perceived as
creating such barriers because we've got
a considerable Surplus in production we
want to make sure that our trade with
the external World outside world is as
open and as free as possible so we're
taking this into account but you have
underscored a very important item the
European Union has got the highest
standards in terms of food quality and
security
uh we have safety we have a very
elevated environmental
production food production standards and
what is happening right now is that we
need to pay more to Farmers for adhering
to these standards and we will start
paying Farmers for making sure that
certain standards are observed even
those standards that used to be observed
prior prior to that date for instance
Animal Welfare
we are going to be paying out special
amounts concerning better welfare so all
these elements which
constitute high standards in the
European farming will be rewarded
farmers will be rewarded for that
thank you commissioner and a
supplementary question is still Church
uh
commissioner I really respect your
efforts but as opposed from my
colleagues from the left I don't see
sustainability in the commission helping
these or those when the price of food is
increased we have to have the conditions
for producing enough food in the
European Union we mustn't be stricter to
the European Union producers than those
from third countries is your priority
foreign well I'd just like to point out
because
I I already switched this off uh so I
apologize to the interpreters this is
question time for a good reason we need
to restrict ourselves to put in
questions when it comes to supplementary
questions you then came with a point of
view that is not why we have the
question time and as we have too many
requests for the floor I think we have
to respect first of all that you don't
overdraw on your speaking time and
secondly you stick to your your question
Mrs hazacamp's next
four seats up
president commissioner
food is a human right and we must ensure
that everyone has access to healthy food
according to commission research we see
that there is a risk of
increasing food prices leading to people
not
eating healthily
but sustainable healthy food must be an
accessible option and that can be done
if you get rid of VAT on fruit and
vegetables across the European Union how
is the commission going to ensure that
citizens in all member states have
access to fruit and vegetables without
vat thank you
foreign
thank you very much
of course this is one of the tools that
could possibly be used to increase the
affordability of healthy food
such tax incentives could be envisaged
scrapping vit or at least decreasing the
vit rate well this is not my job to make
promises in this respect other
colleagues are responsible for this as
I'm very sure you understand but I would
welcome this direction of travel
decreasing taxes or scrapping taxes to
help people especially the poorest ones
we have such schemes such as fruit and
vegetables at school we have different
instruments making it possible to give
food to charity we're in favor
thank you very much Mr kellehan now
yes food inflation at 18
input cost to a farmers running at 24
inflation is having a significant impact
on lower income families across Europe
and is now having a significant impact
on Farmers to be able to produce food
itself so to ask the commission first
and foremost what is it going to do in
terms of addressing the input cost
primarily fertilizer and other commodity
costs like protein feeds for animals for
example to convert to meats or milk
production and that is going to be a
significant challenge now I would like
to know what efforts will be made to
displace the importation of soya Maize
oil seed with crops grown in Europe
under the protein strategy and finally
commissioner we never have had an impact
assessment on Farm to Fork on the
biodiversity strategy or on the green
deal itself so is it not time that we
would have an impact assessment on the
strategies to ensure that some of the
strategies aren't adding further to the
difficulties regarding price inflation
and food inflation
colleague
thank you Mr Kelleher commissionerkovsky
thank you very much for this uh question
concerning the farm to Fork strategy
certainly the strategy being a political
document
is not does not contain a requirement of
Performing the impact analysis of the
overall strategy but we are looking at
the individual elements within the
context of its implementation and we do
conduct import impact assessment for
these thank you very much for reminding
us about this strategy because this
strategy contains a lot of elements that
are supporting
[Music]
um the shortening of this path from Farm
to Fork which is a very long one at the
moment and as we talk about food prices
we also need to think about the
influence of Transport cost only one
third less than one-third of food is
transported
over a distance of less than 50
kilometers two-thirds of food travels
over
50 kilometers and seven percent over 500
kilometer within the European Union
which is also pushing up the cost of
food so if we can support this short
chain supply chain and this will also
contribute to a reduction of food prices
and this is why the implementation of
short supply chains and direct
possibility of direct sale of food these
are these activities are envisaged by
the strategy many member states have
implemented these or introduced them
into their strategic plans and we are
attaching a lot of Hope to that because
we hope that this will significantly
reduce the price of food because the
modern cap with a shorter Supply chains
will be contributing to that thank you
thank you
thank you very much commissioner Mr
Keller supplementary
would the commissioner not agree that we
should base all our policies on concrete
data and on scientific evidence and we
have to move Beyond hope
we have to make decisions knowing the
potential outcome and impact that those
decisions will have and our production
capacity our competitiveness our import
costs and ultimately the cost to
Consumers will increase
will increase we know that definitively
and now we have the added additional
problems with regard to the cost of
fertilizer and other inputs into the
food chain in the European Union so all
I'm asking I'm not opposing I support it
but we have to do it on science
hello
thank you Mr kellehan yes go ahead
commissioner
thank you very much well we certainly
base ourselves on scientific and
evidence at least me myself I am doing
that
and I look at such analysis in the area
of Agriculture but also economy I'm
analyzing the situation throughout the
European Union and also what is
extremely important we need to look at
differences
between different member states
which is also the a certain source of
difficulties in our programming at the
EU level because farming structures are
different in different member states and
challenges are different as well and
this is why we went very strongly
towards a greater flexibility of cap
we've got National let me repeat
National strategic plans and I believe
that this will allow us to better adjust
the agricultural policy to the situation
in the individual member states in line
with scientific evidence
and I'll be I would like to
take this opportunity
responding to your question and one of
the earlier questions as well because
this is a recurring theme
I hear that we are reducing or curbing
the farming production let me stress
once again that in under the current cap
there are no instruments that would be
intentionally reducing the production
even though
there used to be such instruments we
could think that perhaps
the set-aside requirement
and the rotation of crops these could be
seen as potentially reducing production
in short term although the increased
food Security in longer term these have
been suspended they as they might have
reduced our crops in a short in the
short term so today cap as it stands as
it is implemented does not contain any
instrument that would lead directly to
reducing
food production by by Farmers there is a
possibility of producing more
of course we are taking into account the
fact that this production should not be
valid only for today but also in
tomorrow and for the future Generations
so sustainability and agriculture is
extremely important thank you thank you
very much commissioner colleague Markie
please
thank you chair we've all last year just
how vulnerable our food supplies and how
vulnerable food security is and how it
has impacted on so many people well I've
listened to the figures you've given us
here today where less than 0.4 percent
of GDP is is sent on food production and
only 500 million of a crisis Reserve
well if you divide that out by 10
million Farmers that's less than 50
euros per farmer across Europe well I
have one question for you as the farmers
representative within the commission
what are you doing to increase that
budget what are you doing to reduce
their input costs and what are you doing
to increase fertilizer Supply because
clearly these are issues that are
driving up to comprise of food across
Europe and we want to know what the
representative agriculture is doing
within the commission to address this
situation
foreign
thank you very much for your question
the current budget of the cap
the budget implemented now starting from
2021 this budget is not 365.
365 billion Euro but 22 billion more so
we have had an increase as compared to
the original project I do not want to
boast but it was my initiative to
increase this budget it was a precedence
in our history
for the first time we have had such an
increase
as compared to the initial proposal by
the council
but yes
0.4 percent of GDP whereby our
challenges are so huge and the crisis is
so profound yes this is not enough this
is not enough to ensure food Security in
the long term so I keep talking about it
I keep talking about it decisively
uh on many public forear during many
occasions this is my plan I cannot make
any promises or make any statements on
behalf of the whole College of
commissioner I don't have a mandate to
do this I can only speak about what I
will try to do and this is my pledge
indeed that I will try to make it happen
in the future we should have more money
especially when it comes to crisis
management measures during the crisis
Farmers cannot be left to their own
devices
our instruments are intended for an
ordinary situation with occasional
problems requiring our intervention
but today we are not talking about small
distortions but about a huge permanent
burden and a huge risk climate risk
political risk there is a war
but we also had the pandemic which
affected agriculture painfully so our
cap if it is to remain a common
agricultural policy it needs to be
stronger it needs to have a bigger
budget and it needs to have more
instruments to respond to crises and to
help farmers this will be our
a priority when we will be working
on the initial working
uh hypothesis and project vision for the
next budget of course this will be up to
the next commissioner to do it but I
will try to prepare the ground for it so
that the cap becomes stronger thank you
commissioner
an additional question commissioner to
quote your own words in relation to what
are you doing in relation is I keep
talking about it that is that's what the
translation came to me surely the money
you talk about the 500 million crisis
Reserve fund that is part of the
existing budget my question is for
additional money and what new efforts
have been made number one to provide
additional money but equally to ensure
an increase in supply of fertilizer to
drive down to drive more competition
into the market and drive down prices to
generally reduce the cost of production
and to ensure that for those vulnerable
people all across Europe we can provide
a cheap and affordable food thank you
thank you very much
colleague Markey commissioner please
thank you very much I have already
flagged what has been done we did have a
debate on this we had a debate on a
document the communication of the
European Commission on fertilizers
you will remember this state aid for
producers there was such a risk
it was a significant risk that the EU
would stop producing fertilizers because
the production plants were not able to
face the huge input costs I.E energy and
gas there was a risk that they would
have to stop
that they would have to
stop that production or propose such
prices which would in no way be
sustainable for Farmers with our
communication as the commission we have
responded to the needs of the sector we
made it possible to give state aid to
Farmers I know that perhaps you are
going to say that state 8 Aid is not a
solution
because state aid may be harmful it may
distort the single market and create a
conditions hampering a Level Playing
Field but we are going through a crisis
so we have no choice but to make state
aid possible and we did this this
pertains to Farmers affected by a spike
in fertilizer costs up to 250
000 euro per holding this is allowed
this is possible
it's not like this that I myself I am an
Enthusiast of this solution
ideally speaking we would have a Level
Playing Field a perfect Level Playing
Field and the market-based mechanism
because not everyone not every country
can afford to pay state aid but we had
to give this possibility when faced with
the crisis
the commission has spoken out and said
clearly that if the member states want
to modify their strategic plans in order
to beef up the situation of farmers
using organic fertilizers in order to
help them make them less dependent on
expensive synthetic fertilizers if a
member states wants to do it we will
correct the Strategic plans very quickly
to pave the way for this to increase the
independence of farmers
so this is what we can do as of now for
the time being and let me repeat that
yes it's a huge challenge
0.4 GDP is is the money that we have at
our disposal and we need to ensure for
the security and the highest the
strictest standards when it comes to
environment and climate thank you
thank you very much commissioner
oh
if I was on the verge of collapse I'll
give you a few figures regarding
inflation in my country Italy 170
percent
from fertilizers 90 for feed 129 for
diesel and 500 percent increase in
energy costs for irrigating fields
isn't it's not just that one in three
Farms are a risk of closing
there's a risk to the whole Cap's
existence and so I believe the proposal
to bring forward the vision of the cap
to next summer is quite inadequate
now what I would ask you to do is this
why don't you propose a package right
now before it's too late
so that we can reduce the impact of
inflation and offset the
reduction in value of their their
incomes in the
the CP because they're losing 30 of the
value
you can support Farmers without changing
the current budget structure by using
the new own resources flowing from the
and Emissions tax so it's just a
question of having the political will to
adopt that decision thank you thank for
calling
thank you very much
thank you very much for this question
all that I can say is a
um you do not need to try to convince me
I am pretty convinced of that I believe
that such a review and reassessment is
necessary we need to look at the cap
budget in the context of inflation
but let me also
remind you that this budget
it was slow in coming and there was a
lot of discussion and difficult
discussion cap was the object of
discussion and polemics a large part of
the public opinion did not really like
the extent of financing provided by cap
so increasing this budget would be a
political challenge all member states
would have to agree
to that
budget the size of the budget is not
something that the European commission
can decide upon by a single decision
this is a process which I personally
would like to initiate
we also need to make others aware of the
fact that if we make our Farmers
stronger if we can provide sustainable
base for the future food production if
we can
Empower Farmers so that they can
actually meet environmental requirements
that are in place this all will require
us to have a stronger budget a stronger
crisis management instruments we need to
try to convince those that have the
final say that is the member states
and their citizens the citizens of the
European Union thank you
thank you very much commissioner ironic
speakers colleague de Castro
well thank you very much president thank
you commissioner you know very well
that with the increase in prices we have
millions of families in Europe suffering
and the effort that has been made in
order to confront this particular
situation which is very complicated now
I'd like to add something to this
particular battle because inflation
means something for consumers it also
means something for uh the agricultural
sector as well not long ago last August
the Biden Administration
introduced the inflation reduction act
an important intervention instrument in
the United States where billions
billions of dollars were earmarked and
the measures for the agricultural sector
in the United States is a 20 billion
dollar package only for agriculture
Investments for sustainability of
production my question is the following
why why with these difficulties that we
have before us right now with the
Russian invasion in the Ukraine why
Europe can't respond as the United
States responded with that particular
support package for Farmers
thank you very much Mr de Castro
commissioner please commissionerkowski
now
thank you very much for your question
this question goes beyond
the remit of this debate and beyond my
mandate as it is today
it goes beyond the issues of Agriculture
yes there are European commission is
discussing this issue and considering
its possible response to what the U.S
America Administration has done
you will remember
that the European commission has made it
possible
to pay state aid to support the economy
including agriculture
I'm relying here on data as of the end
of November
Aid
amounted to 450 billion Euro that was
spent or that was earmarked
and endorsed
out of it 90 to be spent by France and
Germany all this to alleviate the impact
of the war the fact that there are two
major economies dominated him may be
problematic but I don't don't want to
dwell on this less than one percent of
the state I'd went to agriculture even
though it is eligible
we have 250
000 Euro as a possibility per holding
under the current budget
state aid is a good tool it's a good
tool in a crisis situation it's not an
Ideal tool for the single Market in
general a lot here hinges on the
individual capacities of the member
states thank you
well thank you very much
commissioner our next speaker's
colleague
president commissioner
your Bromwich shows that 93 of European
citizens are very concerned about the
increase in food prices and they know
test this every day but what you're the
Euro barometer survey also shows us that
94 of people want to live in an
environment will live work and enjoy a
sustainable environment and of course
Palm parcel of this is an ecological uh
environment and economy
so the prices
of
organic agriculture have increased far
less than conventional agricultural
products so this is shown once again its
strength so we don't want to see a
reduction of environmental standards on
the contrary we need to see an increase
in environmental centers hence my
question to you is there something that
could be done in the short term to
strengthen this particular beneficial
cycle in the long term how do you intend
to make sure that this flows into the
common agriculture policy like ronenberg
thank you very much
commissioner please
thank you very much for this question
I cannot but agree to all that you've
said
um this is true that organic farming
seems to be resilient especially under
the covet crisis this is when we saw an
increase in consumer interest in organic
farming products we do have a plan for
developing organic farming and organic
farming production which is very
detailed some member states are working
on drafting their own National plants in
this area so we are very strongly
supporting organic farming the
development plan this new regulation
also which has been implemented recently
which includes some facilitating
measures concerning group certification
and very strong
instruments supporting such farming in
cap
in both first and second pillars
I haven't gotten this data at hand but
the amounts that have been earmarked for
supporting organic farming have been
increased and I deeply believe that it
will keep developing I share your
opinion the development of organic
farming constitutes an alternative
solution to many farms which are facing
the Dilemma of whether to be an organic
farmer or quit farming altogether so
this is a way out of this dilemma
because we hear very often that organic
farming is more costly and it will not
contribute to product to food security I
do not share this view I believe that
organic farming supports and strengthens
food security we want to develop it and
member states have received very strong
instruments supporting that especially
in the Strategic plans
so they can draw upon both pillars the
first and the second thank you foreign
yes what you've just said is very
logical commissioner and this role of
being it dependent on petrochemical
intensive
agriculture we need to show the error of
these ways with
um figures and that's why organic
farming is done very well hence my
question what specific instruments do we
have for the coming cap round
to take on board the fact that public
money will go for public produce
thank you very much Carly commissioner
please
thank you very much
I can only say that I was personally
working on and making sure that organic
farming is included in Eco schemes the
practices that are being implemented in
those Farms so that independently of the
support to farming could also be
provided by Eco schemes and I wanted to
have a maximum support in the second
pillar and please believe me that we had
a very tough negotiations with all
member states as we encourage them to
provide a very strong support to organic
farming to improve increase their
environmental Ambitions and the the
index that we want to achieve 25 percent
of organic farming in the European Union
by the by 2030 well I'm not absolutely
sure whether we will be reaching this
target of 25 because it it is a huge
effort and it is not only up to Farmers
but we are on the right path towards
achieving that there is a lot of
interest on the part of farmers and it
will also depend on whether on our scale
on our ability to increase demand for
organic farming products this is very
important for Farmers this is all open
there may be preferences to organic
farming products for instance
organizations that are providing food
and Catering to larger groups of people
can also have a preference for organic
produce and this is also legal and
appropriate so we have great hopes we
hope that already in 2027 as we wrap up
the cap or during its review we will see
a stronger position of organic farm was
thank you
thank you very much commissionerkovski
Onyx speaker's colleague lavacek
is
thank you commissioner
inflation is skyrocketing this affects
all prices in Europe including food
prices and I hope we don't
we won't be seeing the same levels of
inflation this year's last so something
has to be done
we can't just have plans on paper they
have to reflect be reflected in reality
and a study from Edinburgh University
have said that the main problem with
prices
of energy and fertilizers are really at
the core of this I know you've
undertaken a lot but the strategy that
you have framed is weak I'd like to
support you but at the same time request
of you
can we not make a further step towards
resolving these issues please work with
commissioner Simpson so that we have a
clear framework for the production of
fertilizers
talk with commissioner timmermanz so
that we can have a rapid transition to
Green sources for fertilizers
speak with Miss kiriakidis
so that the margins can be
achieved
thank you very much
when it comes to fertilizers and the
availability and affordability the
commission speaks with one voice and
works in One Direction we have had a
document on fertilizers it was adopted
no one was against there was a consensus
on this
so I can only reassure you that we are
working together as a team here the
instruments at our disposal have been
used we were rocking our brains to try
and think what more can be done
how can we help farmers
for the time being I don't know what
could be added to this communication I
don't see any potential to add something
to this of course the uptake of this
incentives in the member states is of
key importance here how will the member
states support organic fertilizers a lot
can be done
Eco schemes when it comes to Eco schemes
we are not imposing anything it's up to
the member states to to use them upon
taking into account the individual
specificities Energy prices everyone
here is well aware that there have been
disputes in the council
it was a very controversial issues it
was very hard to take decisions in this
respect
we all know that the member states tend
to differ on a number of issues and
their interests are not always
convergent so the decision-making
process was a
difficult but we did arrive at the price
cups for gas it was a huge step which
should go a long way towards improving
the situation of fertilizer produces
farmers and consumers thank you
colleague
well thank you very much commissioner
verchikovski
colic modelers are next speaker
well thank you very much president
commissioner the issue today is not only
a problem of member states
uh because of course the situation the
Ukraine has had effects throughout the
world 50 percent of the wheat in the
world is hoarded by China and they've
stocked up on that so we have increases
in prices
internationally International
companies are making major profits on
all of this and at the same time farmers
are in a difficult situation in Dire
Straits so why the commission under
these particular circumstances has
has and not looked at the major
restoration law and secondly the
fertilizers natural fertilizers on the
one hand
and on the other hand however the
commission is doing everything so that
livestock raising in Europe that it be
reduced considerably so those two issues
together brought together what is your
point of that thank you very much
colleague Butler commissioner vojakovski
of the Floridians
a
[Music]
foreign
thank you very much
you could say that the commission uh
strives to limit
production or or breeding now the
commission rather is in favor of Animal
Welfare
over the last decade the number of
a Livestock in Europe fell from a 122 a
million
of of a cattle
now we have 113
pieces of livestock
we have fewer mixed Farms now I mean by
those those which combine plant
production and animal production
it is a shame and we we should uh go
away towards restoring such forms of
production because such Farms
are more sustainable more balanced they
produce uh their own
feeds or fertilizers
now we have also the Eco schemes which
should
translate into improving of the of the
situation now now as regards animal
production
there are no reasons to limit a such
production however
intensity of such animal production is
quite different throughout Europe there
are countries and there are sectors of
production where we see a lot of
intensification
where
animal farming is turned into an
industry we don't we don't support
turning agriculture into industry
from that sustainable balance production
and Animal Welfare is
supported under cap
in the previous
Financial
framework we had
one billion and a half euros and now we
have seven and a half billion euros so
five times as much money so I think this
is a quite an important
support for animal production thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you very much
thank you very much this closes the
question time the next agenda item
s
so the next point on the agenda
is a statement from the commission
on the latest developments
in the corruption allegations and
influence
of Morocco
efforts to improve transparency
and accountability in the European
institutions
I'll give the commission the opportunity
to change over as rapidly as possible
and even Force itself
and we'll also have a change of
president